hi Team Coco what are things over
another I bet I'm gonna leave and go oh
you know I should hey Team Coco my name
is Jason Ritter and I'm gonna show you
some of my favorite youtube videos the
first one is a music video for a song
called sugar water I'll watch it a
million times I still can't figure out
exactly how they did it it's beautiful
and amazing
[Music]
my next favorite video was really hard
to choose because it's mainly a guy that
I just got obsessed with for a couple
years his name is Dax flame two in a row
you could watch our Superman or a
celebrity day at school I think it's
called good morning when the next one is
called humiliation when he realizes that
celebrity day is next Friday even though
he's dressed as Superman just walking
down the halls dressed like these
regular clothes this next video is one
that I just find very sweet it's a
little girl who's telling her mother
that she is not afraid of monsters and
it makes me happy every time I watch it
and tell mommy again what you said you
were gonna do to him if he came here I
said I've got a kid she's asked oh
that's not nice my next video is
appropriate for Team Coco it's actually
a clip from Conan that's one of my
favorites with Norm Macdonald and
Courtney thorne-smith I made a movie
with carrot top
okay but what's the movie gonna be
called if it's got carrot top in it you
know what a good name for it be what's
that norm box-office poison this is my
last video um it's a little plug for one
of my good friends Jeremy he did these
things called drunk history that is now
a show on Comedy Central but it started
off as a little YouTube thing I
recommend number three for no real
reason
Khan Oni
she was nice to do spy a Frenchman
she said I have tasted the truth and a
freedom that is so real you know the
whole words but I've changed to the
truth in her freedom
[Music]
thank you so much for watching all these
fun videos I don't know it's here
[Laughter]